PROFESSOR: Welcome
back to recitation.
In this video, what
I'd like us to do
is answer the
following question.
Suppose that f is a continuous,
differentiable function.
And if it's derivative,
if f prime is never 0,
and a is not equal to
b, then show that f of a
is not equal to f of b.
I'm going to let you think
about it for a while,
see if you can come up with
a good reason for that,
and then I'll be back
to explain my reasons.
OK.
Our object, again,
is to show, if f
is continuous and differentiable
and its derivative is never 0
and you're looking at two
x-values that are different,
show that their y-values
have to be different.
Show that if the
inputs are different,
the outputs have
to be different.
Now, this might remind
you of something
you saw in lecture about if
the derivative has a sign,
show the function-- if the
derivative is positive,
show the function is
always increasing,
or if the derivative
is negative,
show the function is
always decreasing.
So this is a similar
type of problem to that.
So what we're going to use
is actually the mean value
theorem.
If you'll notice, I have f.
It does satisfy the
mean value theorem
on an interval from a to b.
I haven't even specified
which is bigger, a or b.
But it doesn't
matter in this case.
So what do we know?
The mean value theorem tells
us that if we look at-- well,
let's just write it out-- f of
b minus f of a over b minus a
is equal to f prime
of c-- and what
do we know-- for
c between a and b.
So we want to know whether
or not f of b minus f of a
can ever be 0.
We're trying to show
that it cannot be 0.
So we're going to isolate this
expression and show that this
subtraction cannot be 0.
Well, how do we do that?
Let me come over here to
give us a little more room.
I'm going to rewrite
the mean value theorem.
I'm going to multiply
through by b minus a.
So we get f prime
of c time b minus a.
Now, we just want
to show, again,
that f of b minus
f of a cannot be 0.
What's the only thing--
well, not only thing,
we know two things-- what
two things do we know?
We know f prime of c is not 0.
That was given to you.
f prime is never 0, so
certainly at any fixed value,
f prime of c is not 0.
So we know this term is not 0.
We also know that b
is not equal to a,
so we know b minus a is not 0.
The only way to get a product
of two numbers to be 0
is if one of them is 0.
So this in fact, this
product is not equal to 0.
The fact that this
product is not equal to 0
tells us f of b minus f
of a is not equal to 0.
And that alone is enough
to conclude that f of b
is not equal to f of a.
So, again, let me
just point out of this
is probably reminds you very
much of the type of thing
you've seen where you were
showing if f prime had a sign,
then you could determine whether
f was increasing or decreasing.
It's the same type
of problem as that.
It's exploiting what the
mean value theorem tells you.
So I think we'll stop there.